[Music]
you
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you
[Music]
you
summer of chess comes to an end as 20
international grandmasters compete in
st. Louis u.s. chess champs calm
presents the third annual fall chess
classic hello and welcome back to round
seven of the fall chess classic we're in
the homestretch here Dennis it's been
six exciting action-packed days of chess
so far more to come yeah and definitely
more to come the players show no sign of
slowing down
no signs of really any any fatigue
coming into round seven here of course
they're just nine rounds in this event
so there are just three games to go
including today the most exciting part
is just straight ahead of us yeah coming
up in these next two days everything
will be decided
so these players have nothing left to do
but put put it all on the table go
all-in and start scoring some points so
why don't we see where we actually stand
currently in the a group it's the story
of Ray Robson ray of course got off to a
slower start this tournament he drew his
round one game and then actually lost
his around two game but since then he
has won four games in a row and he's
looking to make it 5-2 impressive yeah
clearly deservedly at the number one
spot in the a group right now Jordan on
forest is also chasing ray with a very
formidable score of three and a half out
of six there are still a myriad of
players all on 50% but they are
definitely running out of time I would
say Dennis running out of time to catch
up to Ray Robson especially if he does
well today and then there also a variety
of players at two-and-a-half out of six
why don't we check out the B group in
the B group yes or quesada Perez has
jumped out to a very strong lead with
five points out of six in even higher
score than raindrops logging the early
reader yes Jack temple yeah jack of
course was the story of the B group in
the first three rounds actually scoring
three points out of three but has since
only managed to score one more point in
the in the latter three rounds of this
tournament
following them our Dennis caters around
Paco bian and Steven Zurich all at a
very nice score of plus one and three
and a half out of six why don't we take
a look at the format for this tournament
all the players up there in the
tournament hall are competing and 210
player round robins that would be this a
group and the B group the time control
that they're competing in is 90 minutes
for the first 40 moves plus 30 minutes
for the remainder of the game thereafter
they are also given a 30-second
increment from move one and there is
also a draw rule in effect the players
are actually not allowed to offer each
other a draw until black makes his
thirtieth move as always we wanted to
thank you guys for joining us here in
the YouTube chat sir wordy I hope you're
getting your pizza my friends Rob to do
[ __ ] supernova Kappa one six one one
thank you all for joining us if you guys
have any questions for us any questions
for the players once we get them in for
an interview if you'll read a lot of
snow in that YouTube chat we will be
keeping an eye on it if you also want to
get involved on Twitter use the hashtag
fall chess classic to tweet out to us
and as always you can follow the games
for yourself live on us chess champs
com2 see all the action for yourself
well Dennis it's about time to take a
look and see what the players are doing
today so let's check out the pairings in
group a vara Cobian squares off against
Fran Tanuku Mian you Arden run forest
the number two player in the a group is
actually taking on Alexander Linderman
and breaking news I believe they have
just drawn that game so Darras roots has
drawn alexei batalov already alia
smearin takes on alexander bortnik and
our key matchup of the day is with Seif
dura bali against Ray Robson and you
know what they say about this one Venice
yes it's going to make for an excellent
game of the day game of the day game of
the day game of the day game of the day
alright so there we see the players why
don't we check out what's going on over
the boys well lots of action
and seems to be getting to the touchdown
zone Wow
it could be five out of five yeah five
in a row is I've been the row is
impressive almost unheard of for an
event as strong as this with him back
2,600 level plays and this would be and
a middle five out of five yeah
interesting that a you know taught up to
that kind of slower start but has since
really found his form and is dominating
this tournament obviously one piece on
this board sticks out to me more than
the rest that is this very strange night
on e7 yes and that will potentially be a
huge issue but let's take a look at the
beginning part for a second all right oh
my god this is a caro-kann a Carroll
Khan are you familiar with the caro-kann
I believe this is the pan of line Dennis
yes and it is a black plays very
naturally with night of 693 96 and now
white plays Bishop g5 back in the olden
days of course white would love to play
Knight f3 and then after but black would
play Bishop to g4 very often players
would try their chances and what's known
as the endgame line but that hasn't been
a very popular since I believe like the
1980s or something they gave that one up
a while ago the Bishop g5 line is of
course the Bettina Corey ation yet
trying a bit harder to win but now ever
since the I believe the 90s there's a
famous game between taupe olive and lock
o where Lecco managed to win quite
convincingly with this Bishop e6 move
it's a very interesting line and it's
been a quite popular ever since yeah and
probably this caught there are badly a
little bit of guard even though g3 is
probably critical I think Bishop takes
f6 is better than C five point being
you're trying to lock in this Bishop
playing against the bishop e5 Knight g2
and black has counter chances here
probably a six and g6 Bishop g7 there's
Bishop bare compensating for the defects
of the black position it definitely and
it's not as though blacks pawn structure
is really all that horrible yeah the
deep on a slightly weak but these four
pawns on the Kings side actually worked
together quite nice
defend the black King and potentially
watch an attack later on and again and
in fact this d4 pawn can get super weak
absolutely in fact black often even goes
bg5 saying that if you ever posed and I
don't have three I'll go G for now
attack that guy
but anyways white man for G three D
takes ninety five and this was a pawn
sack Oh interesting
Bishop 9 G 286 Bishop e3 in g5 what a
nice and aggressive move it's kind of
refreshing to see these active brave
moves when you're so used to seeing g6
in all of the classical games definitely
you can imagine that a there's going to
be an uncomfortable amount of space for
black on the Kings side whereas White's
pieces aren't really set up to take
advantage of this weakening move so
actually the fight is revolving around
the d5 square right so Knight f4 might
be potentially dangerous for black is if
I managed to exchange this I might be
able to push the 5 yeah it's it's the
age-old saying the way to take away the
way to fight against the Knights is to
take away their squares you Knights have
no squares they're not very useful
so this g5 is a very big star move as it
takes away the key square of f4 h4 and
black says that I don't care about pawns
as long as I can start developing and
castling and I'll be happy because this
is an isolated pawn which will be super
weak in the future of course black is
already up upon to begin with here yeah
he's just giving it back yes Queen a4
Queen d7 so black so far is playing the
role of reverse Robin Hood but he's
playing for the good reverse Robin Hood
reversed Robin okay it's actually taking
the foiling from the poor and giving it
to the rich yes okay so in any case
these bishops are working really hard
and has no real issues here so even if
black will to lose the pawn
black would still have firm control yes
and there's also this problem of a d4
pawn as well yeah immediately right I
don't know if a d4 on I probably can't
capture because can't capture five is a
little bit loose and if you would take
this truck I might just capture it
eventually oh yeah definitely
so a3 was played Knight c3 takes Knight
d4 but this was near a blunder as luck
is up a lot of pawns black is probably
close to winning here in my game so
Knight d5 those plates hoping for some
big counter play but bay is known to be
a cool player he's easy 697 a king c7
and after this line this is what really
struck me as odd me you know white
obviously didn't have the best position
with the knight on c3 but now he's just
he's giving himself an extra problem
yeah I don't see why my right really
white really felt the need to go in for
this I think did our Bailey safe was
trying to hope for like aggressive
counter play and hoping for the best
because he thought if he's just waiting
around probably he's going to lose in
the long term
sure so he was hoping to get some
counter chances quickly but it seemed to
have backfired as yes he wins upon but
for the compensation for that pawn is it
is not strapped yeah absolutely I don't
know it's not as the rheya played some
line to refute what white did Raiders
played the most natural moves and now
it's clear but what's idea just wasn't
very good yes but in any case I think
this Bishop e6 line seems to be in very
good shape and you we can't really blame
that move that's a little strange but it
seems to work yeah of course
you know white was was in a lot of
danger you straight out of the opening
here we'll have to get rain if he does
manage to win this game yeah this is the
mood to talk to us to talk about would
be a huge win for him he said some crazy
performance so far and it looks as
though he's he's well on his way to
another win here yeah sure and this is a
the current position we have I guess yes
alright so yeah ray deep in thought
trying to find the best
way to continue here why don't we take a
look at what's going on in the B group
actually do that we've got the B group
pairings up here a rhombic Obion is
playing Stephen Zurich Stephen of course
after yesterday managed to defeat him on
Hamilton yes and what turned out to be a
marathon game they were here I think
upwards of six hours playing well into
the evening
Aman Hamilton has already drawn his game
against Alexander fair Denis Kendrick is
playing Manuel petrosyan and what looks
to be a pretty interesting position
we'll have to take a look at that later
Victor mihailovski is playing a veteran
gorian and then our key matchup of the
day is the Group B leader
yes sir Quezada Perez in the group B
second-place player Jackson Bulli ak
squaring off in this round seven and
these two players of course a lot on the
line here this may be Jack's last chance
to kind of come back into this
tournament and really try to win first
place however looking at the past few
rounds the trend seems to be in the
Astor's favor yeah he keeps scoring more
points and Jack is floundering a little
bit yes it was definitely and let's take
a look at this position so blacks pieces
are a little bit dis coordinated but
it's a closed position so who cares this
looks very Carroll Connor asked as well
yes so give us an expert opinion
exhaling worried you would be here with
black with black white to move white to
move so a big problem for black is he's
managed to break through on this e-file
but somehow he ended up leading with his
queen which is you know generally not
what you want
in general what can sometimes just
consolidate on the C file if black tries
to open it up too quickly and why it
just doubles his rooks on the C file I
can spell some serious trouble for the
black pieces would you be very des back
if you would get this position so I
would have to do a very specific
calculation I think I think blacks idea
is if a move like rookie to c1 were to
be played like is just going to try to
trade the Queen's and then kind of
consolidate maybe go into some kind of a
endgame where he shouldn't be losing
even if it is slightly worse for him so
you just predicted
happened exactly right Luke see 797 and
I think we can give full props for this
move Lex says okay take my pawn you have
to develop yeah this is something
something to expect very often if black
is not getting checkmated in the
caro-kann there's always some option to
go into an end game and end games are
very difficult to win for white in the
CARICOM especially with a weak eeep on
like this and even that H pawn may may
come under fire in someone's yeah
definitely in the long-term past bonds
are good yes and in the caro-kann you
get plenty of those as the D pawns often
drop after c5 breaks and yet here the d5
fun is just awesome
so again Quezada gets the chance to take
the pond he does so knight c6 Bishop c5
exchanging rooks
and this has in some ways the spirit of
the banker the spirit of the monk oh yes
the spirit of sorrow then Oh spirit of
sorrow oh but you mean a pressure along
this pressure along the B file and the
fact that you're down upon but you have
real peace bet pressure on pawns and
pawn structures right Bishop d6 will be
six again after Bishop d6 the situation
kind of improves for white as this pawn
gets extra defense and now the rook can
move freely and this Bishop kind of on
the ideal square on Jan 6 not only does
it defend the e5 pawn but it also
prevents a move like rook b4 but you can
get kind of annoying attacking that H
pawn yeah this rook might enter through
and enter and post itself on e4 and then
it's very difficult to defend that
ponics right so Rafi six was played
nigth I actually don't understand
I think White's simply trying to play
the move F 2 F 4 yeah used to really
solidify this moment but it yeah I don't
know for some reason I feel that it's
like good jump in the dark
yeah I don't know why why this direction
for the night yes like what is it
actually doing there
tonight g5f four of us played kind of
stopping that idea interesting at four
rooks c1 bishop eight-six interesting
decisions
so I guess black might want to take it
because this night is somewhat better
than this Bishop is this knife can hop
around into position and is also
constantly harassing that a5 form yeah
it's an interesting position in fact I
think the night might just want to stay
on c6 I think blacks threat right now is
simply to capture this Knight and then
play King g7 Kingdom that's C ok f1 yeah
takes and just walk up yeah I'll just
come up the board and issue is I can't
really kick you out cuz you just sit
yeah I've got the nice light squares
this bishop in fact I doesn't do
anything because there's only two pawns
on black squares the rest is on white
squares if I were white hieratic I would
actually be seriously concerned that I'm
going to lose the skin yeah it's it's
very hard to meet this and we might even
ask questions about the five phone as
well of course white doesn't have to
allow this though yeah probably
simply Knight f3 is the best move but
yeah but so might admit some some defeat
with Knight g5 idea yeah and I'm not
entirely convinced that this should be
like super bad for black especially King
walks could be interesting or just
trying to get rid of this bishop yeah I
really like this idea of just moving
this King forward it seems difficult to
stop of course there are some tactics to
look out for yeah the King can't
immediately land on f5 due to or takes
c6 yeah so here here here and this is a
no-go because rook takes c6 and we say
goodbye us that means which may be
disaster
I'd say it's hard to miss but then that
kind of reminds me of the game fear me
huh Lipsky where it actually happens
yeah guys do your tactics very important
stuff
I know daro has been doing a lot of that
puzzle rush battles on chest
calmly a it's been interesting to watch
a player with his caliber
yeah do you do stuff like that but it's
it's been fun to watch so it's actually
not that easy to make progress here with
white but because black might be just
waiting you're kind of stuck defending
this e5 pawn and you if you start
pushing then you create weaknesses
yourselves as well definitely nothing
said probably probably just to draw here
probably just a draw but it's like a
dynamic equality so anything could still
happen yeah I agree
zoom that there's still a lot to fight
for it feels like the type of position
though where the player who tries to
press very often becomes the player with
the worst end of things yes very easy to
try to over press a position like this I
feel well those are our games of the day
where do you want to head to next okay
so talking about Alexander fear he just
drove it Amon Hambleton yes indeed so
that's a first move the first step for a
month to get out of this bad tournament
yes only a couple more steps to go yes
it's actually let's take a look because
we can still learn from games where
you're out of shapes of sorts so g6 c
for d5 not surprising fear plays the
green felt and Hamilton doesn't refuse
it
alright takes takes and this is
something to do when you're in poor
shape or in poor form play the main
lines yes what could go wrong nothing
according to this game the 5 according
to the laws of chests the laws of chess
if you play the main line you get a good
position yes you build the center you
defend the center very natural stuff and
you should not be in huge danger as
you're probably going to have a stable
center I don't think that objectively
why should fear losing
and in fact it will never happen among
goes and tries to weaken blacks position
black in turn goes and weakens White's
position and you know where I'm going
with this I know where you're going with
this more exchanges more exchanges okay
exchanges take places to go oh my god
opposed to the colored bishop and the
game which is actually a little more
pleasant for white as you cannot
essentially space around that black yeah
but but objectively it's just a draw
understanding takes age 3 and the draw
has been agreed all right well there are
some quite imbalanced games going on in
the a group if you're interested in
checking that out it seems as though Mel
Coonan actually has a pretty nice
position against Barra a Kobe in here
alright let's take a look although that
King seems to be dancing in the middle
dancing in the middle Kings are bad
dancers did you know that I did not know
that but yeah this is something we've
seen from bar before right so he had
that game in the Grune film yeah where
his King got stuck on a one as well and
stayed there until the end I'm in the
middle with you yes yes um the issue is
the Queen's are better dancers because
they can move back and forth that makes
you a good great mover ok um but the big
issue is that you have to waste time and
your king is still not safe on e2 rights
you need at least to play rogue d1 and
to be totally safe King f1 but that is
actually three moves that's a lie agree
if only you could play King up one rook
e1 and one turn and say castles and get
away with it and I'm not sure if you're
familiar with this guy he's called some
Carlson magnet magnet magnet magnet neck
Magnus that's yeah Magnus Carl so he
used to say that if castling takes you
three moves forget about it
right yes it's like it's dodgy then so
King e2 black might just go are and
immediately try to open up the situation
very dangerous and especially with this
Queen totally out of play and not ready
to defend the husband on he to this can
get very dicey so it would be eight
problem is rook d1 look t1 I'll play
naturally Queen b3 and I wanted to put
pressure on your king
yeah I'm feeling I'm feeling the heats
feels the heat I guess I have to play
like rook c2 d2 and then just a kingly
one if you give me a check
yeah actually computer suggestion is D
Phi which is pretty pretty nasty as h5
is the threat it's just not kind no it's
not just not kind yes and I guess I have
to play h4 h4 but yeah we can't we can't
on a screen is not doing great they're
definitely not Laura Samantha Lee is in
big trouble
I'm not seeing that the knockout blow
yet for black butts I know but
definitely a lot of pressure on this
King on actually both members of the the
white royalty here the king and the
queen both facing some danger from these
black bean and the other problem here is
that you can't even go to f1 and g1 as
the e3 pawn is constantly under pressure
yes yes just a very uncomfortable
position very uncomfortable so this will
be a tough one too old but we've seen
what seen waar survive yes similar in
his game against derived badly
speaking of kings in the center though
it looks as though Alexander bortnik is
making his whole castle in the center
he's got all of his pieces around his
King and I'm not sure if it's it's the
greatest thing I've ever seen
yeah
you see a bortnik shaking his head just
slightly he's not trying to show off but
I think he's kind of noticing that even
Knight d5 stuff might be in the air yeah
that's 95 is a legal idea then you're
sad it's quite dangerous yes
no I noticed uh perhaps pawn d5 is also
possible I can take I meant - yeah for
white I thought this yeah yeah but I so
many so many means for white so the
problem is this c6 fawns super weak also
anytime you go here I take and I just
collect it isn't very dangerous
let's see that he actually make a move
yes seven okay okay so still ninety five
is a problem so first off this looks
like this pawn is a huge issue both can
even the e6 pawn can we go like Queen
III of sorts well yet my original idea
was to play pawn to d5 and I'm the pawn
85 I wanted to play Knight takes h5 but
I'm not sure yeah how about getting away
two months yeah I mean letting black
walk up the center exactly like we have
a comfortable pressure on the f4 yeah
I'm with the knight on f4 and rook on e
WA Nani six so d5 actually would help
black I would consider playing Queen III
just winnings upon because black can't
move the knight for one it's illegal for
two I would even take your queen if it
wouldn't be it's the older double pin
double pin yes make sure I put my queen
- III sir there's no Bishop g4 funny
business and to the love of my life I
can't tell what's gonna happen and who's
gonna stop me from taking that e-cigs
font it's it's an excellent question and
I don't have the answer for you I think
black is probably just planning to play
like king c8 here and hope for the best
yeah so king c8 but then I think I'll
take and that's it yeah I guess I have
to take back and then you have how many
attackers on e7 a 1 a 2 a 3 and a force
I think that's too many yeah that's too
many people act to do it's one too many
exactly one too many and yes so this is
looking quite good for Ilyas near and
yet so it'd be a shock if he doesn't
manage to win it what's be a
well-deserved win for Ilyas Mirren as
he's been playing very nice fighting
chance he's not had a lot of interesting
position was this tournament yeah and
win here would actually bring him back
up to 250 percent overall which is a
very nice score um and hopefully this
game will give him some boosts yes it
was a delight seeing his fighting games
even though it never it didn't really go
his way but they were always
entertaining to watch absolutely and
just taking a look at this position here
for received Urbani against Robson I
mean back to the game of the day I feel
like the the end is nigh yes this
[ __ ] has been disbanded
yes his pieces have abandoned him yeah
just they've gone to the Kings side and
a knight has appeared on c8 but not not
a lot of friendly friendly pieces around
that white king i meanwhile ride
betrayal if I was a white monarch yeah
meanwhile the entire black army seems to
have made made an appearance yes
so what can you even try here think
after you take c3 maybe b4 b4 but I'm
kind of scared of ya know c2 because I
take you can give a check or two right
now yeah three check okay okay
came back to that score Knight d4 yeah I
just don't run into some counter
Tricky's counter Tricky's not that it
would change the value yeah I think I'm
even winning after Bishop f1 and
ambition
b5 but okay yeah my turn so my night
enough one is serving an important
purpose yeah what else can I try
perhaps I just I don't know improve my
pieces Bishop d4 or something attacking
attacking the f2 now I know that this
one is random but let me give you a hint
of for an idea should be first probably
pretty good mm-hmm but I wonder if you
know what I'm suggesting so you remember
the famous game short Timman in the alle
kind very famous I believe this is uh
this is the one where a Nigel short of
course moved his king of the board a
haha love her checkmate is such a thing
possible here just in king b5 yeah I was
thinking that this might be an
interesting idea but for that one moment
this night would be useful I think this
king's advances but let's say Knight
takes a seven then maybe he could
actually do that King journey yeah and
that's why you learn the classics yes
you actually consider ideas like this it
is getting a bit silly though it does
there are easier ways to win this game
yeah but on the other hand now it's
funny like the computer says that
because of this King c4 King b3 idea and
this specific line it would be mate in
12 moves Wow
the King a powerful attacking piece yes
you have your name so never forget about
the classics of course classics that you
know really improve your chest it seems
as though you know this game got very
famous you know it's a very unusual
situation where the King can walk from
g1 to h6 yes but very often in the
endgame it's not so unusual to see I can
be able to make this journey too crazy
I'm serious this I mean the reason I
consider this very interesting as c2
Bishop b2 mate is kind of picturesque
still ah yes where c2 Bishop takes d2
takes away your king's flight software
that's bad here but after this move
we're going to go see to Bishop b2
and the mate is unstoppable yes she's
how amazing unfortunately this is not
fantasy land yeah this is nothing is
trapped on it yes it's trapped on a six
Robson actually played 94 questions what
we should have fun runs into rugby 1
checkmate of course and I guess the c2
Bishop b2 is coming this this looks
looks good enough this looks like the
end is there any way to keep the game
going at all for waiting no no that's a
shame
yes so another huge win for another big
win for me Robson 5 in a row is very
very impressive
and just taking a look at the standings
here that puts them at five and a half
out of seven and it looks as those
nearest competitor is going to be your
Devon forest at four out of seven so ray
would be one and a half point lead one
and a half points ahead and going into
the final two rounds needing only to
score one out of two to secure clear
first and only needing to score a half
point to at least security break yet he
is going to have two blacks and one wide
game this is true so the last three
rounds are always critical threat and
easiest to falter yeah yeah of course
there's a saying in soccer which I used
to play on my high school soccer team
and the most dangerous score in Chester
City
no no just just high school and high
school stuff just the high school
version the most dangerous score in
soccer is when you're ahead two to zero
because that's when you get complacent
you know very quickly the game becomes
three - yeah not in your favorite yeah
so definitely ray still has some work to
do this tournament but looking very good
for him yeah 500 1/2 out of 7 and dare
we see mr. Tony rich the arbiter of this
event yes Tony rich I'm looking at the
potential win of Ray Robson's I believe
we were graced with mycommerce presence
yesterday and tea rich today the a team
really getting it done for the fall
chess classic up there making sure
everything is on the up and up
in the tournament hall and if he didn't
talk about the guy who brought his
purple yet again oh yes Dennis CAD rich
bringing his very colorful hoody it
brought him luck yesterday let's see if
it can do the same today over in the B
group and it's crazy town over there
easy town yes so it's getting less and
less crazy but let's move backwards a
little bit so he see a bit of crazy okay
oh yeah I see where the crazy occurred
so petrosian's thought that Knight f4
Knight g5 would be fun but Cambridge
said hey I didn't bring my purple hoodie
just for nothing I want it should she
five they very crazy sacrifice the idea
being this bishop controls the very
important f5 square which white intends
to make use of yes and after it takes
Bam rook takes this was the reason you
can't take because Knight f5 and the
knight says hello to the royal family
yet again so Petrosian as good player he
is move the King away h8 very
responsible takes b5 and yes by this up
upon the Petrosian says hey if you gave
me that file I'll use it hello white
King rook g8 okay rook g4 if you would
take that would be the end as I would
just outnumber you yeah this is a common
mistake you see sometimes when you play
the move rook takes g8 you're not
trading the g7 arc for the g8 rook yeah
you're trading the g7 rook for the a8
rook yeah is a significantly worse trade
the a8 rook at first did not contribute
anything to be attack but after this
trade is now serving the best purpose
that it possibly can and this would be a
huge advantage for Petrosian just
compare the usefulness between these two
rooks this rook is happy on the open
file this rook is really sad staring at
pawns yes it could never take also King
gage two runs into this cute little
tactics boom the check check check mate
the check check check mate yes the
famous check
check checkmate and so-caiied rich
played rook G for trying to hold on but
Petrosian is on fire
ladies night takes h3 you you can't
really take because I'll go
h5 in the near future and I made you
forcing this unfavorable yes so so kid
which played King gage to bringing the
purple
yes bringing the purple as well as he's
he's got quite a lot of its colors on
that hoodie I don't know if we we should
have stuck with purple he's a he's got a
horrible dominates a lot of paint
splatters and that's true
so this guy h2 was a pretty nice
practical choice as it's not that easy
to find the right continuation here for
black there's so many attractive
alternatives so how did this variation
work out then so Queen f2 was pretty
good still right the attack is still
raging like sense
rogue g5 white just simply captures this
time with this chaos so this rook h5
check would be deadly so I decided to
capture because why not
I think g5 King gauge to now cave which
is a brave player but still he wouldn't
go King G for this is not the end game
fortune does not always favor the bolt
in this case King gauge to g1 and really
quickly I want to jump in we have some
breaking news in the a group
Ilyas mere nin has smearin rather has
actually defeated Alexander bortnik in
his game and as I see ray Robson also
won oh my goodness all the games coming
to a close right after we took a look at
them so yeah hopefully we can get a
couple of those players down here for an
interview be great to hear especially
Ilyas thoughts I don't think we've had
him in the studio yet and of course reg
Robson our group a leader we doing it
again we would love to talk to him
who's 5 out of 5 5 out of 5 but really 5
and a half out of 7 you can't ignore the
first two two rounds well yeah but even
if you go 5 out of 5 in the middle of
the tournament that's note worth it's
pretty good that's actually the first
moment I noticed our recent us
champion Jennifer you when I saw her
when her 5 out of 5 games in the last
five rounds in her previous championship
yes and that was the moment I noticed
that she has great potential and
probably she's gonna be a multiple times
champion definitely especially you know
getting the first championship before I
don't know even leaving the the teenage
years exactly remarkable I can't imagine
being a US Champion right now with that
of Mines we did kind of cut off Dennis
this game a little bit short how that's
respect the Dennis's yes got a got to
see how this game is shaking out here
looks like that White King did manage to
find its way back home to g1 yes but
what's going on wait we need to up a
piece but there is still there's a
ranger attack going on dangerous attack
so Queen e2 has to be played otherwise
you lose your queen defending the f2
squares so if I play something random
I'll just take your queen of course if
you go king f1 I say bye-bye bye-bye
enough to yes so Queen e2 we takes e4
and this turns out to be inaccurate as
black had to go Queen F for setting up
Knight f3 and Knight age three ideas and
this probably would have been very very
strong never take free pawns yes Queen
takes e4 can get one running away still
he can f5 Queen c4 f4 takes and you're
almost at the game and I takes e4 was
played 91 93 and probably King II 1 will
be played and those pawns on e5 f for a
pretty strong but not that white doesn't
have chances to survive as he has an
extra piece right all right well while
we wrap up looking at this game I
believe Ilyas Miron is actually ready to
come into the studio so I will pop out
of my chair here and while we switch him
back in here let me find Ilias game
so this was a classical modern variation
played by bortnik efore was played by
smearin g6 Knight c3 d6 should be 3a 6
Queen d2 honestly not surprised with the
Bishop III Queen d2 play chosen by Ilyas
Miran because this is the most
aggressive most fighting position you
can have against the modern so 97 h4 h5
and so far very typical actually it's
typical and she's a killer the usual
plan to put nice on g5 where it's linked
so we have Ilyas Marian in studio
congratulations 6 6 was so please let us
know how the game went game with rather
smoothly I would say because I think I
keep strategical my strategy no idea
towards the end I mean to them yeah so
it was my idea to Crump him and to crush
after yet somehow it worked kind of I
felt that this was like the perfect
choice for you to play this Bishop III
Queen d2 system yeah this seems to be
the most aggressive player of the field
almost but I'm not aggressive don't
worry okay so actually I like to play
Pyrrhic sometimes the buff is both
others and actually I have decent
results with both covers let's say so
how dangerous is this for black the
system roughly in my opinion is not
entirely correct I mean I mean from from
South Africa point of view it may be not
completely correct but it's interesting
company nevertheless
which gives blacks chances for counter
play but of course it's very dangerous
from strategical point of view because
give up the center and difference with
convenient that kills Indians at pound
on see to not only see force or white
center maybe it's not so powerful but
it's also same safer yeah not easy what
is it to undermine it so I still have to
mention this but we learn each then say
about the modern because I'm actually
visit Levin each time yeah because I'm
very happy to see someone next to me
who's also a fan of them I'm huge fan of
him of course language town I mean
fantastic player I looked for his game I
mean I was very impressed when I was
like 15 years old and it was Russian
book by was the French teen I think
which was about language time also his
biography short biography and it was I
was impressed by his game and after when
I had chance I started all his game come
in database and it was fantastic player
and I think my style is maybe little bit
similar to him where our two favorite
players for me or for all the time it's
Michael Todd mm-hmm not only because of
his chair if formidable chess success
and and video about genius but also for
which which human being he was he used
to be his sense of humor I was lucky
that I still played with him once and
also I have some conversation little bit
with him and of course I'm probably
worse two players lunchtime and be hotel
way impressed me most of all alright so
let's get back to the game we have very
impressive stuff tonight
age three where is this night headed on
Jafar g5 it seems that he's doing
nothing but from the other side it's
very annoying for black because it's
sometimes it's a take on juicer on f7
and also protects in some variation only
for and also it's impossible to drive in
out driving away after h5 yes and you
never want to go have sex because night
yeah
if there would be amazing rook c8 in my
opinion maybe move provocative maybe you
should play something else but actually
I don't like too much Bishop d7 already
saying true because Bishop there is not
much to do on b7 mm-hmm I would play
something called maybe Knight b6 in
previous movies move yeah not immediate
Oh No maybe h6 86 and also it's a Peter
Svidler I think I didn't similar
position to black just not too loud with
plane because this plane I faced a
couple of brief games myself
we Blake and I felt it's very annoying
so I play tonight h3 after it was couple
of interesting moments night you find I
mean it was in the game if six I think
it's better if h6 is better alright so
Bishop d7 I have a feeling that your
opponent was expecting you to Castle but
then was surprised to see a four yeah
look a so it's possible but we're to
give Blake counterplay that's sure a for
I also use wine before Bishop c4 very
important move just to develop yeah so
he cannot take on history so Bishop
yeah just showing the audience here I
can take why you can even take
consistory with Queen also possible that
was about it's just there even yeah yes
and so it should please 602 to c5 in
fear I think I might strong move you
should play through prophylactic
I don't know what computer says about
didn't check it yet but in my opinion
it's quite strong just not letting Hyuna
counterplay so no trachis yeah so he
played a 5 nah yes I wanted to play I
want to play like
a four a five but I didn't want him to
play C 4 B 3 and to put Bishop on the
one with my on a one yeah that would be
Luke would be start maybe it would be
stronk anyway but I decided to play we
should be one because I have supremacy
in the central he has no counter playing
should've whatsoever so rogue do you
want it's a stratton from my opinion now
you can bring the bishop
support c4 know what else it can be hard
to say yes III see 3b 3b should be one
yeah Bishop quake but no come alive and
oh yeah pieces yeah and this is just I
can ever yeah I can be give up you spoon
and a fork because they for a five him
he wouldn't just she couldn't sustain
yes a 97 you start rolling yeah a for
it's important maybe because if he will
play d5 maybe yes very fine yeah Castle
d5 here and he might take and have a
deeper square view yeah but it's not
such yeah not such formidable attack yet
no it's not that great anymore
so a for I mean who here I decided to
hide a little bit now if now if d5 of
course the frightful yeah of obviously
f5 and and a variable probably fall
apart
so he played next note of 6 which is
logical Castle castle bishop in the
fight when you way yes and it seems to
be collapsing as this Bishop is not
defending it anymore
yeah it's to do was position simply for
Blake yeah I don't know I don't know if
I play to the best move but rather yeah
it seemed like that's a convincing
several caps x9f for if Queen disables
will simple rocky one yeah so he played
qg7
yeah double pin forget it
here I could play maybe something else
but I played on key ones logic cookie
one is logical yeah
and why not just take the pawn yeah and
it really to maybe slightly yeah much
Billy three I'm so this variation of the
picture but completely tied up so gotta
be hard to move I mean yeah
yes time to really go to sleep oh yeah
yeah yeah yeah just harvesting the ponds
yeah no okay
and a very nice straightforward way
actually yeah it should be very smooth
game without much without much mistakes
from my side I would say yes so you had
many many interesting banana games and
continuous mostly mostly yes something
on you yeah I mean but in this recent
tournament here ah interesting
yeah this in tournament I played started
to play badly but after in doctor I
missed I mean completely winning
position against your than 140 yeah what
we need a few times yeah
last time it was an elementary
elementary real insane game but somehow
I didn't make it but you're now back in
the groove with this win and you know
there are three more rounds left - two -
yeah actually two three would be too
much for ya shortly we'll be back and
thank you for coming thank you
[Music]
when you visit st. Louis you'll probably
want to watch the Cardinals for the
Blues what about after the game heading
back to the hotel would be a major error
instead boogie through the city and
discover the music that gave the Blues
their name at the National Blues Museum
Broadway Oyster Bar or even the
legendary Blueberry Hill so whether you
love the Cardinals the Blues or the
Blues come play with us and you guys
know I can't play this right st. Loup is
always exploring we get your autograph
of course I think it's pretty cool that
you love chess so much we love chess too
I draw a school chess program and gotta
meet a real-life Grandmaster I have this
big one time I put a police captain
after school and check my name in 27
moves Wow
I should be asking for your autograph
check out all chess has to offer at st.
Louis chess club org be surprised be
intrigued be delighted the world chess
Hall of Fame in st. Louis is nothing
you'd expect and everything you love
three galleries highlight the history
culture and creativity behind the game
explore chess in ways you never imagined
it's a one-of-a-kind cultural
institution where rare artifacts and
world-class art play together the world
chess Hall of Fame mind art experience
question on Twitter from dem s I should
not have pronounced that that was a bit
of a champion for those of you who are
new to chess it might look like ba3
is an illegal move here because white
masters pawn to square is not one but it
still has something we call autosome and
you can do that you have to do it
instantly you can't wait for a move like
let's say clay King in seven kimchi -
and now try because I'll play for
against Lawrence and now he's going to
play something against me which we
discussed at length during the course of
my stay
yeah he told me this is that d5 this was
what I was kind of hoping for because
now I think he practiced I know Lawrence
this is not how it works
certainly would be much much more fun if
chess actually work like this I don't
think it does well maybe it does well
that's me regretting what I just said
[Music]
all right welcome back everybody to more
coverage of the fall chess classic I
have a very special guest here with me
in the studio Ryan I believe you have a
golden opportunity for the viewers at
home like - this is this is a once in a
lifetime opportunity here what we're
trying to do are sell raffle tickets
these golden tickets to raise money for
our scholastic program so all the money
that we raise from this will go towards
our scholastic programs towards teaching
chess in schools towards doing research
to find out what chess does for you and
other
of your life or other aspects of your
schoolwork but not only that it's a
50/50 raffle so for $50 you get a golden
ticket $5,000 will go to the Scholastic
the Chess Club and then $5,000 will go
to one lucky winner so with a little
cause thank you thank you yes we only
have 45 of these tickets left I've
already sold over 150 but Ryan our
viewers at home aren't going to be in
the st. Louis area
how will they what will they do if they
win the raffle doesn't matter you know
anywhere we've sold tickets we're all
over the world for this so we're drawing
the tickets during our golf tournament
we don't need to be present to win it'll
be on September 30th probably around
5:00 5:30
you know central time and then we would
call you with a wonderful news that you
have won the golden ticket have seen you
in $5,000 so there's only a few these
left they all go sorts of classics and
the rest of it goes to one lucky winner
all right Ryan
well then where are these going to be
drawn so the drawn at the golf
tournament but you can go to our website
it's very clear just go to the website
it'll be the first thing on the page as
golden ticket click on it it is not
something that you want to pass up
because $5,000 a lot of money it's also
very good cause so we we're trying to
get the help from the chest community
because we think that that everyone
who's watching but agrees that chess is
helpful agrees that chess is good for
kids and this is directly going to that
absolutely and I hear there might be
some big names they'd be competing
against in Israel is there a famous
players x-team Bashir legrasse several
of Yasser gen Shehadeh Alejandro Maurice
everybody has bought these so far so
certainly good company to be in yes my
dear is at home you would like to
support the club support chess in
schools our scholastics program be sure
to head over to st. louis chess club org
it'll be very clear just click on the
golden ticket image and buy yourself
your golden ticket for a chance to win
$5,000 and now $5,000 absolutely and now
we're going to take another quick short
break when we come back be sure to stay
tuned we will be joined by the one and
only ray Robson
you may have heard about st. Louis's
world-class museums art history science
even magic
[Music]
but you may not know we have an entire
museum dedicated to play with a 10-story
slide and a ferris wheel on top don't
let all this family fun slide by you
[Music]
whose kids it is st. Loup is always
exploring anybody
[Music]
no matter your age or skill level chess
is a great game to learn and play the
same lose chess club offers affordable
memberships for families students and
individuals there's so much going on at
the club with lectures classes ladies
nights and tournaments in addition
there's always a grandmaster and
residents to help teach learn and play
come join us at the st. Louis chess club
and see what chess has to offer
[Music]
hello and welcome back to the fall chess
classic and we're here we have the
leader who has won five games in a row
May Robson how did this game go for you
it looked very smooth ah well it it went
very well he he surprised me in the
opening um
it's mostly expecting efore I know he
can play the English but yeah efore
seems to be usually his main mood and
also it's tricky playing against us
because we've actually practiced a lot
together so we know you know each
other's openings and styles quite well
so it's a little bit of trying to figure
out what the other person is trying to
go for mhm yeah c4 I decided to just be
in solid c6 bearing beef yeah because I
don't know as far as I knew he didn't
play into the Slav that much anyway and
so here he he didn't go for that he did
play e4 and now it's a pun off yeah or
he also has the option so d5 yeah
taketake and he can play d4 like he did
transposing to the pan up or he could
take on d5 and play some other tricky
lines maybe I'll try to hang any voice
yeah yeah Knight c3 yeah but he just
went for d4 so clearly he had something
prepared obviously I wasn't expecting
this line but I just continued normally
Knight f6 96 and I expected he'd played
Bishop g5 because that's the sharpest
yeah line here and I mean I don't know
that much about this position I used to
play it with white at least a little bit
I think I played it once or twice
someone's actually against Farah Cobian
and I think he actually did play Bishop
e6 against me as I did here and I
remember back then and this was like
2011 or so I noticed that people were
doing able to move g3
so I thought I mean it would be a good
idea for a white just putting the bishop
on g2 okay
and then I saw the ancient says that
black and just takes he foreign pack is
better uh-huh and the point is now
Bishop takes f6 there because of the
move g3 instead of EF six which allows
d5 and white just wins a piece with the
fork black plays Bishop d5 that's nice
little move
yeah and hitting the rook and still
whites Bishop is gonna be hanging so
even if you take on d5 Queen takes d5
still both pieces are hanging and black
should be doing great
so um so I remember that much but
obviously I still check during the game
to make sure my Queens not getting
trapped or something
and also I assumed that he might not
take an f6 of course he might play
Bishop g2 like he did and I had no clue
about this position I just assumed black
you should be doing well no everyone was
kind of freestyling from here on out
he wasn't for him in the he was he
prepared this Oh he prepared it yes so
yeah here now he is starting to take on
f6 and d5 so mostly I was considering
whether to play 95 or or Bishop d5 right
yeah d5 might just give away the bishops
and this might get unopposed yeah I mean
Bishop d5 is definitely less ambitious
he can take or even just Knight f3 first
actually I thought maybe just Knight f3
mm-hmm and yeah I mean maybe I can
equalize but probably why it's not
really risking much right after Knight
d5 it's still white still down upon as
to justify also this Bishop is kind of
doing nothing there anymore because it
never threatens to take and I moved at
the moment yeah it's not doing too much
but the reason I spent a long time is
because after 95 at some point I
realized he'll probably play 92 and I
want to continue with just g6 Bishop g7
after g6 I I was bothered by my f4 here
yeah pressuring d5 and the point is
after I does they take on f4 Bishop f4
what the d5 square is cleared now he's
always turning d5 and can't actually
stop he has way too many pieces on that
square and I mean if I take on d4 he has
me was like we should be five so it
probably just doesn't even work so this
this Knight f4 maneuver was what was
bothering me
yeah and that's why I was thinking a
long time before playing Knight d5
eventually I I mean of course I saw I
could play h6 force the bishop back but
still I wasn't sure what it would do
because Bishop b3 now if I play g6 still
Knight f4 mm-hmm um g6 allows nine f4 so
eventually I hit upon this idea of just
playing g5 not my first idea because
obviously it's a weakening my creation
but just playing g5 to control the f4
square and just putting my bishop on g7
and saying that even though I made this
weakness the rest of my position is
strong enough I have stronghold on d5
now and I believe that should be okay
here maybe this is the only moment we
could say playing 960 can help you
improve your game because g5 actually is
a typical move of just trying to take
away squares which is very typical in
the 960 games I don't know if you agree
with that because you might have played
something I play some 960 I haven't
noticed that like about the g5 or g4
moves being especially strong but I mean
this position is already kind of more
random thinking than a normal chess game
is so yeah I was definitely completely
on my own I was happy to find this this
idea at least I felt more comfortable
about the position now
so h4 h4 makes sense if he doesn't I
mean I guess the other break could be f4
but he can't do it because of that night
and he never wants to exchange that
would just increase my control the light
squares so h4 made sense Bishop g7 and
here he spent a long time apparently he
had analyzed the position up to h4 and
he had prepared against rookie
Oh mg8 and just which I didn't consider
too much because a does hang on to the
pawn but it is more risky I mean with
Bishop g7 potentially I can still Castle
kingside or at the very least we're
going to exchange rooks so neither side
will be able to counsel that way
rook cheated I'm just giving him open eh
file but Bishop g7 is more of the spirit
of like these fianchetto positions like
Greenfeld and things like that you give
away the pawn but you get the initiative
so exactly kind of like a kind of like
the opposite of some moscow game a very
yes or black can just play b5 that white
takes c6 and Queen b6 and just get all
the pieces out yeah so that's yes
so the Trojan are one against Cade rich
so the purple hoodie didn't succeed this
time
very colorful pretty colorful hoodie
indeed
so let's come back to this game and
let's fast forward to the critical
moment okay I have one mm-hmm remark is
after Bishop g7 he he spent a long time
finally cuz obviously he hadn't looked
at it and I thought he really had to
take on g5 here take take take and take
on g5 again mm-hmm getting back the pawn
and I thought he's actually fine I
figured I'm probably fine as well mm-hm
but you have a good control of this I do
but it's uh it's quite tricky for
example one move I'd like to play is
just Queen d7 preparing castling then he
might play Bishop takes d5 which is not
the first thing you think of and then
Knight f4 and now yeah there's some
problems with the Bishop d5 is coming if
the bishop moves and there's also Queens
coming to h5 and someone hitting the
bishop hitting the bishop hitting f7 in
some positions as well yeah so yeah this
this was not clear to me at all I'm a
funny way of losing of the ship blue to
be yes to put it on page one and you
take the bishop alright so let's look at
game mm-hmm well I think at this point
I'm up to pawns
he can of course get one back at some
point taking XI 5 or a seven or
something but I'll still be able to
maintain the pawn advantage and I also
have good pieces so at this point I'm
clearly better yeah so 95 but this was a
jump into the fire
yeah actually I I mean I thought he had
to move 95 but honestly I I mean I first
like calculated a tiny bit but then I
just only looked at other moves because
I figured 95 just simply can't work I
mean tonight's going to e7 even if I'm
not trapping it it's just stuck there
I'm still gonna be up at least upon and
just positionally I should be winning
somehow and that's exactly what happened
I just took I didn't try to trap tonight
but I just played Bishop to a4 which at
least practically I think was very
strong and now it's just like White's
down upon his knight is stuck and he has
really no no moves no way to get the
knight out immediately and is always
back rank Fromm's if his reliefs the
back rank then I have route 51 check and
I have a meeting net on his King so
eventually all your pieces corralled the
King and even here we kind of considered
this you he has this check but if you
would ever reach this even that would be
super dated and came to a two-night b3
993 checkmate this yeah so night see for
the knight c4 and i already or saw this
idea very very unusual made and this c2
is a very nice way to finish because
Bishop b2 is impossible to stop yeah
Bishop b2 and rook do you wanna look at
he wants unstoppable duo through it so
big win for you how do you feel after
winning the fifth game in a row I feel
pretty good I don't think I mean it's
very unusual I mean for anyone to win
like five games against everyone who's
basically at least 2600 huh
of course nothing like this has ever
happened to me either I may be the
closest was in Mongolia I bet I
determine where I did very well but I
wasn't winning like five in a row
maybe I finished plus five but it wasn't
just one after the other so I don't know
I don't know why it's happening I mean I
think I'm playing pretty well but and
actually a four out of the five games
I'd say I deserve to win like I was just
playing better throughout most of the
game the one game which was the
exception maybe was against Lenderman
where I didn't deserve to lose or
anything but I was defending most of the
game and would have thought the most
likely outcome was a draw but again I
mentioned to keep going that's right
that one too somehow right so keep it
going and best of luck for the rest of
the rounds and see you next time
all right thanks you're getting back in
and let's take a look at what games are
still in progress let's take a look at
the Malcolm young game not Kumi on a
Cobian whoa it changed a lot
hmm it's interesting so last time we saw
the king it was waltzing in the middle
on d1 but since then it found healthy
penisy on a2 which is kind of a nice
achievement let's take a look how this
transpired so we left off around ig6 in
g3 c5 book seats around here yeah and we
thought of what was in a lot of
Challenger yes on a dangerous but clean
a6 was played which is weird honestly I
would love to have my queen around your
king yeah me as well maybe black was
hoping to open the C file somehow yeah
teenage six is as Caleb points out
defense to c8 rook but the king is not
that far away from safety on the Queen
side yeah he he made a run for it yes
and he then succeeded like the royalty
must F as if it feels responsibility
for their nation yes creasing chief war
the king did not pay him in crimes yes
and the king ran away because if you're
a monarchist you must have the King
alive and it actually will survive on a
- it's fled to Monaco yes they fled to
Monaco indeed
Brooksie one green g3 check ok eight and
suddenly why does all right
the King has safe somewhere here black
does have this extra pawn but it doesn't
seem to be very useful and now actually
it's the white pieces that are to be
preferred I I mean peace activity wise
definitely perfect 95-97 ideas might
actually come yeah it's very natural
squares for the night so h5 is kind of
move showing a sign of desperation that
oh my god the situation changed for the
worst
Lee straight Queens with me yeah please
trade with something and watch says no
no Queen trades yes King a to finally
bringing the King into total safety
Queen e2 takes Queenie for rooks e7 rook
g6 and the position is still crazy
there's no room g1 yet because the night
covers that but if white ever manages to
go Knight g5 but you can do it right now
because Queen d5 would just take that's
a nasty little check right there right
it's I don't know everything seems very
very touchy here yes it's very touchy
and this queen is very well placed but
if you would like to get close to this
f8 night somehow yeah you can imagine
maybe rook c8 rook c8 well uh my
thinking was I wanted this Turk on c7
because otherwise black would love to
play a move like rook g3 hitting this
night and I wanted to have Queen f7
check that I don't know if that's
actually the most important people maybe
I could make a weird move like h4 yeah
just with a pest
I don't touch my pieces and all of my
pieces are or me
King Awad maybe this is the weirdest yes
this one might actually threaten Knight
g5 right yeah this might actually
threaten Knight g5 but then I'm still
not following all of it yeah
King e1 is a bit too mysterious though
so h4 is more interesting because indeed
as Caleb points out you can't go here
cuz check and I'll take stuff yeah
although I'm not sure I look at it now I
might have my g5 yes so perhaps h4 then
is important yes square so how about
Queen f5 or Queen d5 takes hmm I'm not
sure because I like the activity on
black side this pawn can be potentially
very dangerous what do you think of this
onion specifically um yeah I'm inclined
to prefer the black side here yeah
because might be strong yeah the F pawn
looks strong the the D pawn on d4
actually looks a little bit susceptible
of course black is just a couple moves
away from playing something like King s7
followed by a 96 and then already the
the F pawn is rolling the D pawn is
attacked and White's on the back foot
yeah on the other hand white is
pressuring black a little bit and if the
knife could help out somehow and without
losing the game immediately without
letting this pawn along too far it seems
a bit dicey to be dicey so anyways
Cobian did something similar
he played a 4 not h4 right it's the same
thought that I'm not sure what you're
going to do pass your turn fair enough
and indeed Queen d5 happened here we
actually have the exact same position
probably this is an improvement to our
lines yeah an improvement for white yeah
because his extra pawn is on the Queen
side here yeah and so a 4 gets it that
one step closer
he's becoming a passed pawn in its own
right and you're creating threats on
that side of the board
yeah potentially white could go b4 even
rooks III and then hope to push that
upon so practically maybe this is a
position where I would prefer a white
little just a little bit well yet wait
to move I'm tempted to play a move like
let's see Knight e5 here and then these
threats of rook c8 followed by something
like ninety seven are becoming a lot
more real yes I want to push the f-bomb
sure I seems reasonable enough but rook
c3 perhaps I'll just I'll just guard
that square dutifully 96 yeah look d3
oh you're gonna do mean things to me I
see it happening already probably not I
was thinking Knight g5 and ig5 and my
idea was for but I thought you're going
to play f3 and that was that was one
mean thing that I says it turns out this
is oh you yeah perhaps which is perhaps
not quite good and amazing alright well
maybe because there's bad for me that
yeah because there's no Queen c4 chicken
if you move here stopping me from there
still checking I still have another one
not that one in the end Queen this one
that's the one that's the one it's a
very interesting endgame over there yeah
I think that Akopian has slightly
preferable chances
what will exactly happen not sure it
could still fizzle into a draw but I
mean this a pawn seems more dangerous
than this Fe yeah of course there's the
principle of the outside past pond
yeah the a pond is much farther away
from the center of the board so it's a
lot you really have to sideline your
pieces and we have to try to stop it
speaking of any end games though there's
an interesting one I believe going on
between Quesada Perez and Shambu lyac in
our key matchup of the day in the B
group so why don't we take a quick look
and see what's going on here
and danger danger
yes at the mark on strikes it's a strong
opening dense I must say it wasn't
actually a Karl [ __ ] was a modern but
it's a ma it's a modern turned into a
Karl may as well been a care of the
whole time yes so we kind of left it
around here black wanted to get rid of
that Bishop right that would also weaken
this pawn yeah widely black just wanted
to get rid of his own Bishop a yeah he's
like can I take your knight no I can I
take your bishop but he keeps getting
deny it yeah and denial this hard even
in chess the rejection is tough to face
a for Bishop e7 and now the King starts
its mighty walk but then that this
Bishop really has no place to go and
suddenly it's stamboli AK who's playing
for the win and this happens so often in
the calculus where you reach an endgame
and then all of a sudden all of blacks
moves come very very naturally and the
white player starts to suffer some
pressure and this is very uncomfortable
for white as these pawns start roaming
and also this extra majority is not a
majority anymore yeah as I just walk up
and take you the black King so much
closer to the action half in the white
king going to be a lot of danger here
for a white yes what position do we have
currently though so we currently have
disposition interesting that like
actually goes back why I see so I can't
go king c5 because f3 and I'll take the
e5 pawn okay but still what about King
d5 King d5 seems totally reasonable to
me and I don't know I would think like
as chances to win this game yeah I have
that same feeling but okay so he went
back maybe just repeating once yeah you
could also play a move like a funny for
here maybe
for wouldn't that drop that pawn on f4
potential maybe it would maybe be a good
I'm just trying to find that blacks
reasoning here how about we started
collecting pawns let's go back let's go
King F 1 maybe 97 95 is that an idea
looks reasonable yeah uh if possible
maybe I want to go to e4 instead but I
have a calculated that King in Polish
yeah I'm not a hundred percent sure that
this one's winning it would be great but
why why calculate why not just take the
pond cuz e4 is a better Square and you
got to play accurately yeah that's a
fair argument but why okay so
ninety-seven maybe King e2 Nate c5 would
be a very serious problem yeah I have
big chances of winning that pawn so
actually owned in the game it seems as
though black did just want to repeat the
one time yes now taking a five instead
King f1 which was a mistake it turns out
that 98 97 would have been better
interesting yeah just I guess the
pointing out that you know maybe black
spawn is not so safe either
yeah so if you go King before I have
knight c6 check okay and that can take
the pawn before you munch on all of my
pawns right and once all the pawns are
in the same side of the board it does
become a lot more difficult to win yes
but my plate King f1 rushed and you
should never rush in em games right
there they're very very and they're
they're so concrete yes they're very
concrete and you have to be super
precise to actually when you have a good
position the advice that I always heard
is that if you struggle in the endgame
yes you can study specific end games and
try to improve at that but probably the
main reason for that is you actually
struggle with calculation it's deep
calculation in the endgame that really
uh you know ends up converting to full
points and so that's what you should
really train in order
to improve yeah so Knight f6 and either
if you want to go there Caleb way you
could go Knight e4 double setting up
this double threat gotta love the
central squares or if you want to be
more conservative and go my way you can
go Knight d7 night c5 sure and from
those two you should be able to find the
one that you like most
well let's let's play some moves here
actually is white just simply losing is
white going to take all of these bonds
so let's go Knight d8 okay in 94-94
since I get to play the move yes so that
that's gonna ID for this is annoying
yeah you're not that time with Nyepi I
want to do an ID b7 but then it drops
the pawn and I'm think I'm just lost
because you take that pawn and you have
an extra pawn on the other side yeah
Xillia the the King on f1
proving itself to be a horrible
detriment to audition so I feel that
this is a big chance for stamboli ACTU
right bounce back in and this would be
incredible for the groupie standings if
Jack were to win this game he would
actually tie his opponent yes or quesada
Perez in the lead for the B group with 5
out of 7 yes and I guess with Petrosian
winning yep Petrosyan did win his game
as well putting him at 4 out of 7 and so
that puts dennis who was the next
closest chaser still back at 3 and a
half and then lastly the other important
game that we have not seen yet is this
game between Iran poco bian and Stephen
Zurich Stephen is the other player with
three and a half out of six and a chance
to jump up to just a half point behind
the leaders with the wind today but
that's not looking like the case here is
Eric looks to be in big trouble deep
trouble let's back up a little bit so
this seemed like a very normal position
up to here White has the bishop pair but
this bishop on f1 does really nothing
mostly just defending again
Bishop has become a theme though in this
tournament is one player having the
bishop pair and it looking not very
impressive and then all of a sudden you
fast forward 10 moves in that place just
totally winning the game so I think we
are actually heading towards the end of
the tournament as black plays Knight d5
and drops upon Wow
that is intense because it's least try
night before I don't know did he just
play Bishop f5
what did whoa what exactly did he think
like there is Knight takes a forward
then then Bishop b6 and you can't stay
on the 8th because if you do I'll take
your knight and if you move back rank I
think you're reaching the end part of
the tournament and people start making
mistakes and mistakes big mistakes so I
think Steven sadly just drop the pawn
he's dropped upon ship f5 it's not that
there's no hope defending this but a
pawn is a pawn and the bishop there is a
bishop there
yeah and that should that should seal
the deal for white I would think but how
did the game actually progress
so actually Zarek could have tried to
build up some sort of structure and try
to hold some white square defense yes
some light square defense but instead
try to be aggressive and we can see a
relaxed aram Jaco beyond just stretching
and having a little drink rights as his
position is just improving minute by
minute
so this rook on a5 was especially dumped
but the problem was solved by zerk he
helped him restructure it and move it to
c3 never good to force your opinion or
your opponent's pieces to good squares
yes
and now eventually all of white pieces
are just prime Lee positioned to attack
he's also trying to move forward or just
climb down these weak pawns Knight b3
but exchanges are pretty good when
you're up upon right and now three no
rush just likes a 5s looks quite bad and
the pawn was taboo because that would
just win the and the game oh there's a
very interesting line with D for
checking d3 but you still cannot catch
the pump yes very fun stuff so d5 a very
nice tactic yeah by Cobian go beyond
king e7 and v6 was played in d6 and this
this should just be devastating the D
pawn is far too strong if nothing else
white can play something very very
simple like bringing the rook over to
let's say the e3 square and then up into
e7 which is and should I collect all the
pawns so this should be when in fact
yeah this should be very good for
Huckabee on and this would be a big
result friend all right as we come to
near the end of our show here it looks
like there are just a few games left
remaining so we're expecting Jack to
possibly even win this game against a
yes or casada Perez we have not yet
taken a look at I think this molesky
game against a veteran gorian so what do
you think's going on in this rook and
game black seems to have a couple extra
pawns but is it more complicated than it
seems
well it does feel that it's around 50%
chances for both sides to win and a draw
so black has real chances of winning but
White's active pieces gave a fair chance
of drawing as well especially this king
and the King being active making itself
quite useful you can imagine it running
just from e3 to d4 and then one of the
black rooks will have to give up its
active play in order to defend this pawn
also notice that this King is not down
here when it would be clear that white
is completely lost rights
trapped on the first drink is here it's
not that simple because black is going
to lose one of the pawns either the a or
the C Gregorian is trying to decide
right now which one to do and give away
but in each case the activity of
Michalowski scheme might prove enough
for a draw all right so there are a few
interesting end games left to watch but
unfortunately we are running a little
bit short on time so why don't we take a
look at the results we've had today so
far in the a group so far
vara Cobian is still playing this game I
can scranton oku mute and once again we
are beginning to slightly favor white in
that endgame yeah so it's still anyone's
game to be certain
Jordan van forest drew his game with
Alexander Linderman daro drew with
Alexander epitaph Ilyas Miran won his
game against olexander bortnik and a
very impressive showing Anse the Pyrrhic
really just dominating in the center and
crashing through on the black plastic
game by classic player yes and then
lastly in our game of the day Ray Robson
managed to defeat received ER by Lee in
a very impressive caro-kann his fifth
win yeah he's no fifth win in a row
nearly unheard of results against the
field this strong yes
makes you wonder is this Ray Robson guy
going places pretty soon of course he's
he's already spent some time in the top
100 but perhaps this is this is the time
for a sixth American player to start
making a bid for a 2700 style level of
chess let's hope so huh it'll be fun
just fun to watch for certain and over
in the B group what we have going on is
a romhack Obion still playing against
steven zurich of course we see in that
end game that steven is in quite a lot
of trouble with the white pawn on d6
Aman Hamilton
drew his game quite quickly today
against Alexander fear Denis Cade rich
the man in the the colourful hoodie yes
actually lost to Manuel Petrosyan today
Petrosyan of course is following the
leaders with four points out of seven
now looking to be a point behind
going into tomorrow let's see other than
that
Victor mihailovski is still playing
against a veteran gorian and that
doubled rook endgame he's fighting for a
draw against a Victorian yeah fighting
for the draw there and then lastly in
our key matchup of the day yes sir
Quesada Perez is still playing ejection
and buuck and the position is only
looking better and better for Jack as he
seems to be moving quite quickly to the
Queen site to collect some pawns yeah so
this leaves us with some pretty
interesting standings coming out of
today if Jack were to win that game in
the B group he would be tied for first
place with gasser quesada Perez with
just two games left to go that'll make
for some interesting final rounds
expecting some fireworks
in these last few rounds absolutely well
why don't we take one more look at this
golden ticket promotion by the wonderful
Ryan Chester as he lets you know about
an exciting opportunity to support chess
in schools and get a chance of some
money
hi my name is Ryan Chester and I'm the
development manager for the Saint Louis
chess club I'm here to tell everyone
about a golden opportunity that we have
right now we're selling golden tickets
for $50 a piece it's a 50-50 raffle
$5,000 will go to the Scholastic chess
initiative for the st. Louis chess club
and $5,000 will go to a lucky winner
we're only selling 200 of these and
we've already sold many to grandmasters
and all of our commentary team as well
so if you're interested please call the
Chess Club or go to our website on the
homepage and buy a golden ticket there
thank you and good luck all right
exciting stuff from Ryan Chester well
that just about does it for our show
today
important to note ray Robson is going to
be ahead by what appears to be one and a
half full points after this round points
and let's put some in a very unique
opportunity tomorrow he plays the only
player able to catch him at this point
Jordan Vaughn forest so if he were to
win that game tomorrow he would clinch
the a group with a round to spare be
sure to join us for all of that action
at 3:30 p.m. tomorrow for round 8 of the
fall chess classic and once again we
would like to thank you guys for joining
us on YouTube if you'd like to still
follow these games for yourself on us
chess champs calm please be sure to do
that definitely some interesting end
games still going on yes so and other
than that we'll see you tomorrow for
more action at the 2019 fall chess
classic
[Music]
this has been a presentation of the st.
Louis chess club
you